this is the theme bismillah
alhamdulillah Salam alaikum peace be
with you you're watching the Deen show I
may be your host
every week we're here bringing you a
fresh new topic and my next guest is a
former musician that's right and he's
very young and he was living that life
and he was all about music it was all
about song and dance playing the drums
playing the guitar having his black dad
and trying to reach for the stars trying
to be a pop star but is that really what
you want to be in life is that really
who you want to follow and emulate you
want to emulate the hip-hop stars the
Britney Spears and the Lady Gaga and
Lady goo Goo's is that what will bring
you success in happiness well he figured
out that you know what that's not the
way to go and he went another direction
we're gonna find out about the direction
that brought him peace and happiness and
is bringing him success in this life and
something to look forward to beyond
comprehension in the next life we'll be
right back with his story here in the
Dean show
please be with you so now I like on
peace be with you are you doing more
good hundred a lot have yourself now you
Oh hundred lon we thought your story
would be a benefit to those because
there's a lot of people trapped in that
lifestyle that you got out of yes so
they're trapped you got out of the trap
and you're here with us today
hum little oh and I now you went from o
to Mohammed yes I went from o to Mahalo
yes yeah so tell us now you were living
the life of a musician yes music for the
longest time was my life like when I was
raised I was raised in a family
we're from Palestine Gaza and it really
wasn't until about middle school when I
really started getting influenced by
music big time and at that point that's
when I realized like the same time I
really started getting involved into
music was the same time I really started
going away from Allah that's when I was
really influenced by a lot of bad things
and looking back now the fuel for all
that that really drove me to do it was
music because music if you really look
at all the messages and like everything
it talks about preaches and endorses is
the exact opposite of everything Allah
tells us music is all about you know do
drugs do whatever you want to do it
messes up all your priorities it really
gives you a false sense of reality this
fantasy you start chasing and it ruins
your life in the process and then once
that really started to happen
I started going down this deep slope and
then a little of the same thing that
really got me away from Allah which was
music
although used to get me
back to him once I actually started
seeing and understanding what music was
all about and how it influences people
and like really how it started and its
agenda today yeah
so you actually come from a background
of Muslim parents yes very very good
Muslim parent were you very okay so
they're practicing oh yes praying
worshiping God on his terms not their
dessert you know you got a lot of
culture mixed with Islam some people go
and do its mom one day out of the year I
think this is not Islam is a 24/7 thing
is exactly so your parents were doing it
yes my parents raised me they were very
God conscious they raised me to fear
Allah and also have love for him but
again what like right when I hit about
middle school you know at home with a
certain culture and lifestyle but then
every time I go outside it was a whole
different world a whole different
culture a whole different lifestyle so
at that age I really started getting
confused and really being pulled between
two different worlds and then music was
the one that really pushed me over the
edge because that was kind of like my
sense of peace which I got you know from
which was music like every time I was
sad I would listen to a song it would
make me feel better
every time I was excited you know I
would listen to music every time I was
looking for guidance I would read lyrics
to songs and you know this is really
dumb because rather than seeking help
from the Creator the Lord Most High
Allah I was seeking it through the
illusion of music and like every time I
would hear a song you know like I would
feel very very down and it would make me
feel better for a second but then right
when the song was over I felt right back
to the way I was before I felt very very
bad so the piece that I thought I got
from it it was all an illusion it was
one second and was gone and you cannot
use an illusion to solve real problems
real internal problems for a second you
feel good but it will go away you're
right after that and you're right back
to where you were that is amazing that
you were able to pull out of that and we
really want people because this is a
reality that people are living between
two worlds yes you know there's the good
forces and the bad force yes all right
you know the good is what the messenger
is brought that from the Creator that
have is an earth they all call just like
Moses Abraham Jesus in the last and
final messenger they brought that
message from the Creator to worship and
to submit
so to the one god to be aware there's a
dead judgment coming and there's the
eternal reward of paradise
there's Hellfire and then there's the
satanic forces working the devil and is
this what you said this is one of his
tools that he'll use like we have the
Koran the verbatim Word of God and we
have that call to submit to God but when
you are just making your life revolve
around music 24/7 because people that
wake up with music go to sleep with
music they're in the car with the
headphones and they're in school you
know even in some classes there's some
people like you know they got the mini
like little headphone put it in and some
are even is that addicted and and
they're just like going with the latest
trends and you know going with the
latest styles on what Lady Gaga what
fifty senses do it they're doing that's
their guide those are their messengers
that's the wrong I do that oh yeah I
mean I saw it and I lived it I mean that
was my life everything I used to do was
based around music I mean I used to
literally wake up going to music I used
to go to bed listening to music
literally I would fall asleep listening
to music and people take it for granted
like oh it's just music it's not bad no
it will warp your mind because music is
filled with messages that are affecting
you whether you know it or not anything
you listen to over and over and over and
over again it will have an effect on you
and like Plato once said like he's
ancient Greek philosopher there was a
quote he said he said be weary of the
music that enters your society because
that music could destroy your whole
society so even the ancients knew the
power of music how you know it could
change you in a matter of in no time
especially if you keep listening to it
over and over and over again now that
was one of the leading intellectuals at
that time yes Plato
yes he's world-renowned like one of the
most famous philosophers ever and he
said say that one more time he said to
be wary of the music that enters your
society because the music will could
destroy your society your morals your
conduct everything yeah
and especially music nowadays again if
you look at it all the messages are the
opposite of what God tells us and that
is not a coincidence yeah that is go on
that know that God is saying look
worship God now don't worship Jesus
don't
the messengers got don't worship Sates
and icons and idols just worship the God
who created all things right yes and do
good so good is being good to your
parents there's music teach you to be
good to your parents no it tells you to
do whatever you want and rebel against
your parents give us some examples oh
man if you listen to any songs nowadays
any song from all the way from the 60s
to present its its whole motto is do
whatever you want to do be yourself
don't listen to anybody don't listen to
Authority make your own rules
and do whatever you want to do and funny
enough that is one of the core that is
the only commandment of Satanism which
is do what that will that is the only
commandment they have and that means you
do whatever you want to do that means
you create your own rules you create
your own laws in a sense you you are
your own God that is amazing let's this
is really exciting it's really exciting
we'll be back with more with former
musician mota mohammed back here on the
deed show be right back so if you find
yourself your iman is going down check
yourself
there is non-woody to be worship except
allah alone you got some serious of
music in the car bobbing your head the
50 Cent's oh no it's common sense don't
do things that can hurt people bullying
this had on backbiting stand early such
substitutes as smoking
and we hold it down on a game show early
make sure y'all tune back here on the
Dean show motor Mohammad former musician
young man was there been there done that
it's a dead end and we're trying to
benefit extract the good from your story
so other people can benefit now you as
douse will yes God is saying Islam is
saying something to submit not to
thyself but submit yourself to God do
God's will but Satan the satanic forces
is about do what that will do just do
what you want do whatever you do
whatever you want jump on this jump on
that jump on her jump on him smoke big
smoke that put it here put it there do
it everywhere okay exactly no sin
nothing there's there's no sin if if you
think your god that's fine you want to
worship a rock that's fine you want to
kill someone that's fine and then this
whole philosophy came from a man named
Aleister Crowley he is one of the most
influential people of the 20th century
that shaped culture and very few people
know about him now this guy is well
documented and I really stressed for for
everybody who's watching this to
research this man he was what's his name
Aleister Crowley okay there's songs been
written about him he is he is on the
cover of Beatles albums so many of the
artists today and the past the 60s 70s
80s 90s they talked about this guy being
the role model and their leader and this
whole agenda that's occurring in music
today that's designed to really destroy
the minds and take people away from God
came from this man this man was a agent
for a spy for the British intelligence
he was a traitor to him during the time
of the Nazi so he was also helping the
Nazis out this guy inspired Adolf Hitler
this guy was a cultist
this guy was was involved in human
sacrifices
this guy got kicked out of Italy this
guy once you read his history you will
want to throw up
about all the stuff he used to do but
anyways in the early 1900's he wrote
this book called the book of the law and
this book he claimed was given to him
through divine revelation
kind of like say the Mohammed peace
peace and blessings be upon him how the
Quran was divinely given to him like
those words were not his words there
were the words of the Creator the same
book he wrote it but he said this
revelation came to him from a devil
named Aiwass and I wrote the book
through him and now this is the guy that
so many artists idolized and his whole
goal he said is to change is to change
culture and to make it completely go
loss to deviate culture to get people
into doing everything immoral and wrong
and all the artists follow disguise and
they use music as the tool to push this
agenda for example look at history you
know in the 40s and the 50s look at
lifestyles like look how people were
living like for example once Elvis came
out and like he was dancing kind of racy
back then that was extreme they were
like oh my God look how he's dancing
nowadays you have people naked talking
about killing doing drugs everything bad
and people have got accustomed to it and
the main force behind this was the music
because the music if you look at the
evolution of it it always pushed the
limit to the point where people started
getting used to it and then they go even
further and further and further and
further and because of this the society
has followed the music because they're
so influenced by it and the artists know
this and the artists they use their
music and they put these messages to
push this agenda and we're talking about
jay-z Eminem The Beatles Led Zeppelin
you name it they talk about Aleister
Crowley
they have lyrics singing about Aleister
Crowley and they openly say this man is
our leader this man is our hero and and
you really have to study the artists
belief systems and who they look up to
because that's going to reflect the kind
of music they make and this guy is the
worst of the worst and he is all the
heroes idols and this is the reason why
today the music industry just pushes
these horrible satanic beliefs and again
Satanism people have a real big
misconception about it like they think
it's only you know killing people and
drinking blood and doing those type of
things but Satanism and a core is again
it's do what that will that book that he
wrote that you know he said it was
channeled through a devil that was the
commandment he said and then in this
book he talks about that there is no sin
you are a god
do whatever you want to do you know
anything you name it do it and these
artists they grab this philosophy and
they put it in the music and they attack
people and the devil attacks people in
this way through music because then
because the devil will never go up to
someone and say hey I'm the devil follow
me don't yeah I mean they won't listen
to him to go okay this guy's obviously
trying to hurt us but if he hides itself
behind humans and music they don't even
think about it just like that quote you
know the greatest trick the devil ever
pulled was convinced in the world he
never existed so in the same way the
devil hides behind the music and he
attacks people this way it puts all
these ideologies and beliefs directly
into their mind and the kids listen to
it over and over and over and over again
and it corrupts you it takes you away
from truth and again you're living in
this fantasy and it's and again it
brings you no peace no happiness you
look at all the artists commit suicide
they're all hooked on drugs or miserable
people they're miserable miserable
people it's it's astonishing that these
people that when you look at them no
sane person will want to take them
really who's trying to achieve achieve
greatness
who's trying to be a great leader who's
trying to be a great role model of the
best of character you wouldn't want your
children taking them as an example
because like you said they're committing
suicide because what because they're not
happy they're miserable they're on drugs
they're in rehab centers you know
they're just out of their mind and
they're driving the youth out of their
mind and that's why you see all the
things of corruption out there and this
is one of the tools the one of the tools
out of the many that the devil uses yes
that the satanic forces used that and
there's there's a quote or there's many
quotes in like Rolling Stone magazine
where you hear like Bon Jovi or some of
these artists basically calling the
devil Satan as their Lord yes have you
seen some of these quotes that they're
they're praising him yes I want you to
praise the Creator yes there's no one as
great as the one who created all of this
who gives us our eyes our hearing the
love that we have that were able to love
with that is from the creator of the
heavens and earth is these beautiful
qualities but they're praising the the
devil yep have you seen some of these
yes it's actually it's a
one of those things that you know anyone
watching they should really do research
on the artists and what they believe and
what they say because pretty much these
people what they do is they trade the
hereafter for this world like every time
they say you know this person sold the
soul for rock and roll where that a lot
they sold their soul yes and a lot of
times people think that means that you
know they take their soul out and they
give it to the devil no every time they
say that what they mean is that they are
willing to sell evil they are willing to
promote you know these horrible acts and
destroy people's perceptions of life in
return to get worldly present no
pleasures being famous but you know
touring someone and so forth and Bon
Jovi actually set himself in a quote he
says I would kill my mother for rocking
I heard that quote - yes
Bon Jovi Bon Jovi Islam says the
religion of Jesus Abraham Moses the last
fundamental problem of peace be upon
them honor your mother yeah this is
paradise is under the feet of your
mother and this musician is saying I
would kill my mother for rock and roll
rock and roll I would sell my soul for
rock and roll now why do you want to be
on you want to be a side of honoring
your mother and your parents or you want
to be on this side this is self-evident
this is something amazing if you think
about it you might have been fooled once
for me once shame on who mmm twice shame
on you you who so check this out let's
continue on tell us now there's some
also amazing facts where they get
inspired now they're doing the music and
something comes in them and they're like
I wasn't even right net who's right and
then exactly that's one also like a very
main thing they talk about these artists
again this is them saying it's not he
said she said they said it themselves
they claim to channel messages that that
they say that they are medians which
which means is they use her body as a
vehicle and these shaytans go through
them in a sense they speak through them
they again write lyrics that they say
they didn't write they create music they
said they didn't create they're just a
vehicle because again if Shaitaan shows
himself people will know hey this is bad
to stay away from it but he hides behind
the faces of people again going back to
that quote the greatest trick he ever
pulled was convincing the world he never
existed so he uses these artists to
spread their
believes to spread you know their
ideology to get people away from God and
these artists are willing to do it and a
lot of them talk about it's really
really scary if you do the research how
many talk about you know this song I did
not write it it wrote itself you know on
stage something takes over me and I
don't even remember what I'm doing what
I'm saying singing nothing the Shaitaan
just uses them as a car in this world to
spread all their filth
that's the question who are you
following are you following the last and
final message or centigram kinda problem
honkies be apartment you finally Jesus I
found the most righteous of righteous
men and examples are you following these
people that don't want good for you
they're gonna just lead you to
destruction we're trying to save you
from destruction by calling you to do
good do righteousness be good to your
parents be good to your neighbor stay
away from unlawful sex do it in marriage
and they're talking about jump on this
jump on that do it in the back do it in
the front all exactly this is what the
the lyrics that are out there and it's
just mind-boggling some parents right
under their nose the children at a young
age are getting this information
instilled in them there's a rapper jay-z
very famous oh yeah we interviewed
freeway this is a person who was under
that label he's saying stay away from it
man stay away from it and the musicians
that we interviewed also like from Bad
Boy Records moon the outlaws we've had
them on the show they're like man get
away
many of these people when they wake up
also because they have a concert they
realized this is wrong so this is Serie
T the goodness we're all created an
original goodness not original sin it
starts to come out they don't block it
they don't do that blocking of it what's
called that Crawford you know they give
birth to what's already inside them that
goodness and they step away and they
warn people so we're trying to warn
people so they don't stay in that that
trickery trap
yeah of shaitaan of the satanic forces
jay-z calls him Lucy
Lucifer yeah have you heard this quote
from him have you heard that yes and uh
jay-z also calls his name Jehovah that's
one of his nickname which is God so he's
going on stage telling people I'm Jay ho
ho yeah which is e says that yes that's
one of his nicknames he goes by and you
know he's trying to maybe you know men
the whole concept of you know I am God
and like he has song so many songs
talking about I sold my soul to the
devil
Mikey Hong Kong called the devils and
the whole song is about him trading his
soul and trading his whole morality in
exchange for world wealth again these
people are selling the infinite
hereafter for the illusion of this world
you were you were in that lifestyle
that's what you were sleeping waking up
to and many are you know we were there
we we've done that it's not the way to
go before we go to a break under my
umbrella you know what's that song by
Rihanna now what she's saying there see
under my umbrella a lot of people talk
about the umbrella she's talking about
is the covering or the hurt overseer
which is like her Shaitaan he has her
under her umbrella under her control and
the whole song is talking about that and
the whole jay-z unit they're hardcore
into Rihanna actually was doing an
interview where she said yes I am a
devil worshiper she said it herself out
of her own mouth her own words so no one
pointed to her and then their songs or
symbols filled with satanic symbolism
messages you know be bisexual do this
horrible horrible messages and they're
designed to destroy the youth people
think musics all fun and games but no
this is a tool they're using because
they know the parents also okay it's
harmless its music although my kids
listen to it and that's exactly what
they want people to think when we come
back when we come back there's a song
out there this is dangerous stuff this
is this is out of this is more dangerous
than a bomb man because when it comes in
your house and destroys your family
destroy society because see what's going
on and we want to save Society we don't
want no bombs going off he and I kissed
a girl is saying I kissed a girl and I
liked it yes we're gonna get into that
when we come back crazy stuff here on
the Dean show we'll be right back deaf
and the day of judgment the mercy of
Allah these are the things that finally
made me realize there is no time to
delay anymore I wanted to take my
Shahada right there
the essence of spirituality is to become
more sincere to Las Palmas automatically
death itself it is very very scary but
it brings you back to reality there is a
life which is everlasting and you have
to make a conscious decision of which a
group of people do you want to be people
are having over the people of hell
back here on the Dean show former moe to
Muhammad musician he was there he done
that y'all because we're Texas right my
brother
everyone says y'all down here yeah so
thank you for for being with us we
really hope you know we sincerely want
the best for everybody we want the best
for all of humanity because Islam says
love all mankind and how are you gonna
love mankind if you're not sharing this
information this this message of peace
peace acquired by submitting to who to
the Satanic forces to the devil or
submitting to these these these Lady
Gaga's and the $0.50 submitting to them
by worshipping your worshipping them by
doing and following everything that
they're doing instead of worshipping the
unseen creator who created man and woman
but he's not a man or woman the one who
has given you life he'll give you death
and then you're gonna have to account
for everything on the day of judgment
and at the end it's either paradise
eternal bliss happiness forever ever or
the Hellfire we don't want you in
Hellfire let's continue on with that
song now that talks about I kissed a
girl and I like the and that's not you
know boys saying that and I said I
kissed my wife and I loved it no this is
like not even the guy saying I kissed a
girl but a girl saying I kissed the girl
yes it's by a song by Katy Perry she is
one of the biggest stars in the world
right now everybody knows what's her
name Katy Perry she's like up there with
Lady Gaga Rihanna and it's Katy Perry
that's like the those are the three
biggest female artists and that was a
song funny enough that actually made her
famous and the whole song is about being
a lesbian and little girls love the song
like you literally have little girls
right now
singing a song I kissed a girl and I
liked it they don't understand the
concept of that and being at that age
saying it over and over and over and
over again it's gonna affect them
because these messages again they're
going directly into their subconscious
like whether you're aware whether you're
aware or not this music it's messages
are affecting you and at that age to be
singing that it's horrible it's it's
really disgusting yeah so there's
another one that she's also a rapper
female rapper we take him a nod what's
she singing about oh my god she's
singing about everything if you listen
to any of her songs you'd want to throw
up she talks about
bisexuality doing drugs killing people
it's all about you know the self I make
up my own rules
you know this whole satanic agenda this
whole satanic philosophy and again
people love this lady and if you ever
just like read the lyrics like don't
listen to music just print it out and
read it it will make you sick to your
stomach these horrible words it's filth
and again they're doing it on purpose
they're not just doing it for fun and
games like they know exactly what
they're doing yeah so it's all about now
under the preset fun front fun do what
you want and then fun fun fun and then
you you end up like you know date-rape
right the song comes on and you're
getting in the mood and this that try it
out and he puts the Mickey and you drink
you in a place you shouldn't be now five
guys leaving the room it likes come on
what happened
you just got date-rape right what's
going on we don't want that to happen to
you and what happens now same thing
drinking driving smoking the dope and
fun fun fun you're crippled right yep
you're dead in a car accident all
because why because you got influence
and you got tricked by music just a song
you thought was harmless yeah and it's
funny because even if like you look at
all the different genres and music right
you see every genre and music has a
whole different type of people like the
people that are in the hardcore rap they
act a certain way they all talk a
certain way they all dress a certain way
people in the rock scene do the same
thing they talk a certain way act a
certain way and it shows you all these
people think they're all being original
and cool yet they're all acting exactly
the way the music wants them to do the
music has enslaved them but they think
it's out of their own choice that
they're doing and they're having fun but
know everything you're doing everything
you think you're having fun you know
you're cool the music told you to do
that but they think it's coming from
themselves and that's another deception
of the music yeah and like I used to
always go to concerts and concerts like
that was kind of like me going to the
measured back in the day like I didn't
like I never went to the measure it was
concert concert concert you know and
like you'd get there and be all excited
and you know people dance and cheer and
when you go there and see the type of
people it's disgusting the things that
go on is again the opposite of a measure
just like music is the opposite of
everything God tells us to do when you
go to a concert you see it all there you
see the complete opposite everything bad
I mean you
name it's going on over there and it's
being endorsed and it's being fed so
it's not like you listening to 50 cent
jay-z and Lady gaga and all this other
nonsense and you like hey go and give
some charity today hey I'm gonna go you
know do some good deal nice to my
parents I'm gonna go help my neighbor
I'm gonna that's not you know it's the
gender robbing a bank hurting somebody
through you know doing drugs women you
got to go to the party now because you
got to get your dance on and groove on
and you know all this other stuff that
doesn't bring you closer to God does it
it takes you away and it makes you feel
miserable did that bring you closer to
God didn't usually bring you closer to
God
no it brought me so far away but so pan
Allah Allah started showing me the
influence of music and how it was
destroying me and that led me back into
him so the same thing that got me away
Allah used to bring me back once he
showed me what it really was you know
what I was listening to what was really
going on in the music industry and that
really woke me up cuz I realized hey
this is real these people are not doing
this for fun the devil is real the
corruption of the mind is very very real
and that led me to believe you know that
was the first step but okay if this is
real then there really is a God because
these people are trying to take me away
from him and why is that because he
exists so from there on out it just I
kept looking and further and further and
further and Hum Dil Allah kept showing
me more and more and more and just
confirmed my faith my beliefs and home
did all that led me to where I am today
just a couple more points there there
signaling that were out at a time almost
like did you investigate all the
different other religions that are out
there the ways of life how did you
conclude that this way of life was from
the Creator that it wasn't organized by
man or men but it was organized and his
divinely sent from the crater that
heavens in earth well whenever I started
looking at all the different faiths I
realized that most of faiths they led me
to more questions to more confusion and
there was a lot of answers or a lot of
questions that I wanted answers for is
that they did not provide and it was not
until I've found Islam that every
question I had was answered everything
that I wondered about was answered there
was no contradiction every single thing
is in there it answered everything from
the smallest level to the largest level
to the music industry to the world today
to the Hereafter everything there was
once you read it all it does is bring
peace and knowledge and the more you get
into it the more comfort
you know it is the truth because there's
too much in it and you can't deny it and
but the other faiths there was too much
loops too much contradictions and again
it just led me to more confusion because
you still confused don't look like you
confuse anymore I know hamdullah
you finally did you finally fill that
void is it is your life oh yes before I
used to feel miserable all the time I
used to wake up I didn't feel right I
used to go to bed not feeling the right
now I could die in two seconds and I can
I would still be the happiest man in the
world I come to the left what what
closing comments suggestions for those
youth those adults who are trapped you
know they're listening to what we have
the verbatim Word of God and that
recitation that brings us peace and
living by this it brings us contentment
happiness life is still a struggle you
still have tests but at the end you got
paradise for all of the hardships that
you go through that make you and that
you don't let it break you and you don't
sir come to your lusts and desires and
your passion and you end up being
depressed and miserable you're happy
because you're living your purpose why
you've been created for the Quran
explains it it explains it in detail so
for those people who don't know what the
purpose of life is they're confused they
think all religions are the same you
just put them in one pot and you know
I'll just do my own thing but they like
what you have to say talk to them if my
main thing I would say is don't take
anything for granted don't just follow
anything blindly anything you believe
research it and really understand what
it is you're believing and questioning
things and question them and search
truthfully and honestly
and don't ever base your opinions on
things off assumptions because that will
bring you nothing but pain and grief so
be sincere do your work and truly truly
truly do your research because if you do
that and you are sincere Allah will
guide you that's right that's right what
was a documentary that you had talked to
me about that goes over some of these
facts about music and the satanic forces
working behind them yes there is a there
is quite a bit on YouTube we'll just
type in you know Satanism in music and
there's a whole bunch but a very good
one is it's called they sold their soul
for rock and roll
and then there's another one called the
industry series and that one's on
YouTube but again on YouTube type in you
know sane ism in music and you will see
thousands of videos people dissect and
song interview
of artists themselves talking about it
so but again don't take the music for
granted research the artist and research
what they believe and understand that
because that will lead you to a better
understanding of what's actually going
on rather than being naive and in the
dark yeah because that's how you get
deceived not knowing not knowing he
wants you to know and thank you very
much thank you very much may God
Almighty the creator love reward you
thank you so many it's like I'm playing
soccer and thank you thank you for
sitting with us here on the Dean show we
really want the best for all of mankind
and we really want you to be successful
in this life and the next life Paradise
is real the Hellfire is real the crater
his signs are all around this creation
everything in it Vinge's come by chance
your cartridges come together your body
didn't just come together and you didn't
make yourself where did you come from
God Almighty the creator Allah created
you for a noble purpose now you will
come back to him but you have this
chance now to either do good to live
your purpose according to how he wants
you to live or live according to your
desires make yourself into a god just
like these people have made themselves
in a god and follow them and see where
you end up we don't want you to end up
in the wrong place going in the wrong
direction that's why we're doing
programs like this so you can benefit
and you could head in the right
direction direction that Jesus Moses
Abraham in the last the final measure
said to mankind the problem how peace be
upon them they were the best of mankind
they were the messengers delivering the
same message worship the one unseen God
who created men and women he created the
Sun and the moon and everything in this
universe only worship him submit to him
and do good deeds develop yourself to be
the best human being that you can be and
this is how you can have peace and
happiness success in this life and
paradise in the next and you'll be far
away from the Hellfire what a hot place
you don't want to end up continue to
tune in here to the Dean show we'll see
you next time until then peace be unto
you
you